hello everybody and welcome to another
moneymaking guide today I'm going to be
showing you a really good one I made
about 2.2 mil in an hour of doing this
method it's really easy too uh not any
risk involved you're not going to the
Wilderness you're not risking any on the
flip it's really safe and extremely high
profit margins you can get on it uh you
will need a good amount of starting cash
and one Quest completed but beyond that
no other requirements and yeah let's
jump into it okay so what you are going
to need is the dwarf Cannon Quest
complete uh it's a really quick one to
do has some minor requirements uh but
the biggest thing you'll need for this
is money now you can do this with as
little as 1 mil but I would recommend 10
and then anything I would bring as much
as you can though uh cuz what we're
going to be doing is we're going to be
buying Canon sets uh from the dwarf that
sells them and then we're going to
resell them on the grand exchange um it
has very good margins on it sometimes up
to 25k but more realistically be
probably 10 to 15 and yeah so this how
you do it we have 70 mil exactly and
we'll do this for an hour and see how
much we actually get 70 mil and uh so
what you're going to want to do is
you're going to get a combat bracelet
and then teleport to the monastery from
here you're just going to run south a
bit and um we'll get the map open here
and it's just going to be down this
Dwarven mine area uh it's pretty close
and uh you don't actually need any skill
requirements use the teleports which is
kind of nice you also want a uh ring of
wealth most likely so you can teleport
back to the Grand exchange so once we're
here we're just going to trade uh this
dude you don't want to get into this
screen cuz you're not going to want to
buy the individual pieces you're just
going to want to talk to him uh spam the
space bar go through the chat options
and then you're going to want to say I
want I was hoping you might sell me a
cannon keep going keep going how much
that's not very cheap but you'll take it
anyway and then he's going to toss
uh all the cannon pieces as well as uh
the ammo molds which you'll just drop
and then you're just going to repeat
this until you have a full inventory
um now you don't actually need to um
drop them or anything you can just keep
getting as many as you want all right so
we have a full inventory Now it only
took about a minute and a half to
actually go through the chat options
from here it's going to teleport back to
the Grand exchange now I'm pretty sure
if you have a cannon in your bank like
all the pieces he won't sell you another
one so what you want to make sure you do
is when you come back here uh you're
going to want to go to
set and then just click on the cannon
set it'll pack them all into set for you
and then you might as well just sell
them right now cuz they they sell pretty
quickly but I mean they do take time to
sell um so we'll just go price check one
now
Canon dwarf Cannon set so we bought them
for 750 and it looks like we can sell
them for 760 so it's only 10K right now
um but I have in the past pretty easily
gotten up to let's see here
763 um so we'll pop them in here for a
bit higher since we're going to be doing
this for an hour and we'll see if they
sell for this medium price here and um
yeah we'll go ahead and do this for an
hour and uh we'll probably stop in once
we run out money and see how much we
actually make all right so I clearly
underestimated how long this is going to
take to do or overestimated I guess um I
thought the 70 mil would be almost
enough to do this for an hour but is
been 32 minutes and I'm just finishing
up uh the rest of my money here we just
have two more Cannon sets to buy so I
think I'm just going to take it just
finish now and then just times Whatever
It Is by two because while uh my cannons
definitely are selling in the grand
exchange I probably only sold 20 or 30
of them so far uh so I don't quite have
enough to do another half an hour of
this but you get the idea so we'll just
buy this last Cannon
here and uh yeah we're good to go um I
think the reason is because last time I
did this I didn't use the monastery
teleport which actually is it's actually
a decent amount closer right here as
opposed to there uh so we'll go ahead
pop these in and we can have a quick
look at oh my God I forgot that all
right so we'll pop these two into sets
and then we can have a look at my grand
exchange uh so you can see we've sold
probably uh 10 of them at a 13k margin
and another seven so far at a um 12K
margin so not bad and we'll pop the last
two in here for U about a 12K margin and
uh we'll wait for these to sell now when
you're kind of dumping this many in at
once um the price can go down a bit so
you definitely have to wait uh but the
profits definitely are going to pay off
so we're going to stop it now half an
hour done and we'll come back when when
uh these have sold so we did manage to
sell all the Canon uh sets now it took
probably just over an hour so actually
not too long uh we sold the majority of
them for a 12K profit but we did sell
about 10 of them for a 13k profit um so
you can see if I say that the margin was
up to 20K and 25k you're you're looking
at quite a lot like couple Mill in
profit in an hour but let's see how much
we manag to make in half an hour uh so
we'll claim all the money here I might
as well just hit the collect button and
uh we're up to 7 1 mil so let's have a
price check of how much we made in half
an hour we made 1.1 mil so that means
that if we had had 140 mil to start with
and we could have actually made over 2
mil in profit in an hour um the thing I
really like about this method is there's
you're consistently able to buy this
item the only thing you have to worry
about is the sell price and the sell
price you're never actually going to
lose money on so it's actually going to
be pretty safe all the time um the only
thing you want to worry about is if it's
just kind of a waste of time but if we
open up G tracker you can see here that
except for that very specific occurrence
when raids released um they're almost
always a 8 to 10K profit and sometimes
even more if we go back even further you
can see it never drops down below 750
all right guys so I hope you enjoyed the
video and I will see you guys in the
next
one
pap